hey y'all intended couch here in this
tire tuesday video we're gonna be going
over the model time package which a
viewer recommended to me
i actually used it um in my work
because i've had i've had to do a decent
amount of forecasting stuff
and i thought the model time package is
pretty interesting specifically model
time
actually uses like the tidy models
framework so it's pretty cool to use
especially if you have a background with
the tidy models
it also has some cool models such as
arima boost and profit boost
while also containing like the usual
suspects such as arima
and profit you can also use like tslm
models using their linear regression
so um let's look at the monotone package
open this up i'll cause tidy models
tidy forecast
okay uh wool loadin
tidy models uh
tidy burst
model time and
time tk so time dk will be
uh the uh the package they'll give us
our data set which will be bike sharing
daily
um time tk also adds a lot of like time
series features for modeling so it's
definitely a package i'll make a video
on in the future
but i figured i'd make a quick video on
i guess the model time framework
so let's look at our data frame um which
is byte counts so if we select
was it date is equal to de day and then
count we have our our byte counts for
every day
if we do a basic plot um
we can see
we can see that it's non-stationary so
we might have to do some differencing
which
won't be too bad um let's
first put this thing right there
and then df
okay there you go so let's do some
differencing first um
as for date i'm gonna do month forecast
so
i'm gonna say mutate uh was it
year is equal to i guess uber date
year date
and then month you go to uber date
month date i'm going to group by
uh was it year and month
i'm gonna i'm gonna um
i'm also gonna let's hear i'm gonna
mutate
um the total so total
i'll say monthly count is equal to some
count and also do the uh min date so i'm
in
i'll say date is equal to min date
um let's see here and then i'll say like
uber date
as date
okay
actually do i don't even need that just
set
so min date
i'll say uh month
date okay cool
um and then i'll ungroup that so
select a month
date uh monthly count
um i'll do a distinct um the reason why
i did this thing
basically is um i i just am pretty bad
with using uber date
so i just want an extract like the the
first of every month
with a daily account with the monthly
count so that's why we
why we did that and what we'll do is
mutate our
we'll uh we'll make sure it's i'm in
order which it should be in order
right and i'll make the uh monthly
change which should be equal to monthly
count minus
uh lag monthly count n equals one
so we can see it's working so uh we
had an increase in ten thousand 000 bike
usages
from the previous month so i'll select
the
month date and monthly
change and then i'll drop the n
a because that's bad for our model
okay so now that we have our monthly
change
what we can do is plot this out again
with gdpot
es x equals month date y equals
monthly change
it should be pretty stationary it still
isn't very stationary
that might be a problem we might just
have to go with
just aggregation by month so let me try
this out again
let's see here
okay um what's here df
so what's here if we have our sum
we might not even have to difference it
so x equals month date
y equals monthly count
man i i think we still need to
difference it so i think that's fine
then
okay so if we go back here
drop n a and we'll do that
sweet then we fire dm line
we have that we can also add our gm
point
well um
so now that i'm looking at this i think
we don't have enough data
for it so we'll just do daily change i
think that that's probably the most
straightforward thing
so sorry about that i know i'm going a
little um all over the place
but this is kind of just how i um
approached it
and i'll make it a little bit easier so
if we go to our df
what we can do is mutate count uh
oops mutate daily change is equal to
count
uh minus lag count n equals one
i mute date okay
plotted out x equals date y equals
daily change
gm1 okay so that makes it stationary so
i think daily change will be
how we should be doing it that's fine
okay um i'm gonna just select date
daily change
uh drop the missing value
uh make sure date is still arranged okay
so that's what we're going to do
oops so we'll say uh
create data okay
um and make the station stationary
okay so now let's actually do our
modeling so with our modeling
the main components of it is the model
time
table and that's basically where we're
going to be using a bunch of models
um fitting it to our training set and
then predicting on our test set
and also kind of looking at our forecast
our accuracy and then refitting to
entire data set
and forecasting in the future and giving
it to our you know
uh giving it to our stakeholders or
our managers so let's start creating
some models
uh i think i'm gonna use what theory
did at the usual suspect so arima i'll
probably do a linear regression
and i'll use profit and also use say
like a remote boost
so i'll first do like an auto arima
model so
arima
model rima reg
uh sets engine
auto arima and i'll
fit it to daily change to date
oh now that forgot i totally forgot to
create our
uh train test set so let's do that first
so
rate train and test
sets so with our data set we actually
want to split it
depending on its time luckily they have
a
tiny model says the initial time split
so we can give our df
do an 80 20 split and that's our split
i'll call us our training set
so i'll say train data and on
our test data
and that's important that we use the
initial time split because
um we don't want our our test data to be
something that we've already seen before
so if we actually look at our trained
data i'll say type is equal to
uh train then i'll bind rows to
test data mutate type is equal to test
and then plot this out
y equals daily change color is equal to
is equal to type
we can see how our train set will not
have anything in our test set and our
test set
will not be seen before for any of the
dates
and that's important so if it was mixed
up we basically have a lot of data
leakage so our model would be is
basically be able to see like
maybe not tomorrow's data but it might
see the day after tomorrow's data and
that can make it
infer a lot of things about it so
this is a good way how to make sure to
not cheat um using the initial time
split
um i think this visualization actually
really shows why it's important to do an
initial time split
um so it's a pretty cool thing of why we
use this different time series split
and it's not very hard to do um one
thing i think it's kind of interesting
is you kind of don't need to set your
seed because your proportion
is kind of setting what um what uh
samples you'll be using
okay so we have our training data um
we're gonna fit that
to our our model so data is equal to
train data
uh we'll build a was it a profit
model so i'll say profit
reg set engine to
profit and then
fifth daily change to date data
is equal to train data
cool um actually i'm gonna load in the
did i load in the uber date package i
need to load in the lubridate package
the library uber date
okay and i'm gonna do a tslm model or a
linear model so
when you're reg set mode to
uh set what's it engine to
lm and then fit daily change
um and within linear regression it can't
handle dates so you have to convert your
date to
numeric and also gonna add some monthly
seasonal factors so i'll say uh
month date label is equal to true
and i'll convert that to like an ordered
factor so factor
and our data will be our trained data
so basically what i did is like converts
it converted this to like a
a continuous variable which would be
like one two three four five
then our month i create a month which
will be a label
and i'll fit that to with the model
finally i'll do like a
uh arima boost boosted
model so i'll say arima boost
um i'll say was it uh tree
depth will be like now i'll just do like
was it uh
learn learn rate is equal to 0.015 and
i'll say min n
is equal to two set engine to was it
arima
boost i just wanna make sure it's called
a remote boost
uh auto arima boost there you go
so auto arima boost i obviously i throw
one right to the
thing that they offered i think that's
kind of like a good way to do it just
because you're only using
essentially date um
but we'll do that so then i'll say fit
daily
change ask.numeric date
plus factor
month uh
oops date label is equal to true
data is equal to train data
okay so we have our models oops what did
i do linear
that sets engine
no date as that numeric date
oh day or daytime verb oops what did i
do
oh and then i also update plus
as that numeric date okay so we have our
list of models
um now what i'm gonna do is use the main
function which would be model time
table add these models into it
oops profit
model tslm model arena boosted
model and this creates a table of models
so i'll call us
a forecast table
right so these models have only seen the
train
uh set so we can do is model
time and calibrate and this will
basically have it predict
uh onto our test data set and we can see
what it's doing so
test data okay so we have our a little
thing that says collaboration
um we can also see what our our arma
models are doing so
when we're not boosting our errors we
have a already
array model with zero zero two or a q of
two
uh with our auto remote with xg boost we
can see how this change with a p of two
uh so it's kind of interesting to see it
change like that we can also see
uh model time like accuracy
and see our metrics so so some
forecasting metrics we should be
aware of is i think mean absolute error
and mean absolute squ was its
uh mean absolute scaled error
so what i've been looking at is mean
absolutely scared scaled error
essentially uh it's kind of the roc aoc
score
of forecasting so with mase
if you have a score of one it means that
you're performing just as well as a
night forecasting model
so an i.e forecasting model would just
predict the value that happened
the day before or the period before
so if you get a score that's lower than
uh one
that means you're outperforming the um
naive
forecasting model which i think is good
especially since
a naive forecasting models do have very
low
error um if you don't account for
scaling and uh
stuff like that so that's why uh people
generally don't use
rmsc or root mean squaredair um they'll
they'll go for p smape m a p
or m a s s e great
so we have this thing right here uh what
we can also do
is we can say model time
forecast and we had this cool little
forecast with the confidence of low and
highs
but what's really i think cool about it
is you can have a model time comes
with a plotting functions so we can kind
of forecast this
and we can say it was our actual uh
plot model time forecast and say actual
data it yields a test data
so we can see our actual right here uh
we can see what our arima with non-zero
mean is just kind of predicting one
value
we see our lm has a little bit of
variance but it's not only doing
anything and then we can see this
our profit model and then we can see our
arena with non-zero mean so it's not
doing
great which is kind of interesting
uh we can see but it's in in case it's
doing anything weird
um however one important thing is you
should always try to refit your data
because it might be able to detect the
trend even better so
what we can do is model time uh refit
and we can refit it to our actual data
set which i believe we call it just df
right
uh d oops so df so
i just want to make sure we yep to df
and then what we can do is small time
forecast in this case we'll say like h
equals
uh seven our actual data is equal to df
and we can plot this out to see what
it's trying to do
so we can see what it's trying to do
oops
uh you can see here we are detecting
some type of trend
right it's trying to do some type of
jack thing it thinks it's like
towards the end of the week it's going
to be slightly decreasing and then aft
after that it's going to increase
it's what our profit does it's basically
following the same thing but it's seeing
less
little um seasonal issues our lm model
is predicting one thing
and then our updated remodel is
predicting a little bit lower
so that's basically it for uh today
i know we didn't really grip get a great
forecasting model but to be honest
forecasting is very difficult
um and a lot of times it's a lot of
tweaking a lot of tuning
a lot of looking at holidays which i'm
sure i'll start
working on uh more videos about uh for
it
but i wanted to do a quick uh video of
kind of how to use the model time
package
kind of mess around with it and just
show how basically how
simple it is and how it does a lot of
the grunt work for you
so people can work on their own
forecasting projects
so with that said i'll see you guys next
week and tidy on